welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel's secret Invasion
reached its finale with the lowest score
from critics in Marvel Studios history
with episode 6 receiving only 13 on
Rotten Tomatoes now yes I am no fan of
the way Rotten Tomatoes calculates these
scores but from a qualitative
temperature check in the days since the
finale secret Invasion just seems to
have left a universally sour taste in
the mouths of viewers which seems to
come from a disappointment over
characters like Maria Hill Talos and
sorin killed off with really no sense of
resolution to those deaths in the finale
questions left unanswered with how long
exactly Roadie has been a scroll some
inconsistency with the characters of
graphic and gaia's decision making and
gaia's new insane power set at the end
of the series and really just what we're
supposed to take away from the focus on
Nick Fury's marriage and in general all
these missed opportunities to do a live
action secret Invasion and a squirrel
storyline over four years of MCU history
that just ends like this look I'm not
here to do a hate video overall I
enjoyed watching this series and I had a
pretty good time with it for a more
specific review you can check check out
me and mod Garrett's criticisms in our
finale review on the break room and I
did a deeper analysis of each scene in
my Easter egg breakdown but here in this
video I want to look back on the whole
series and analyze what went wrong with
secret Invasion the challenges it faced
the real reason I think we feel
disappointed and I really want to try to
clear up some of the bad takes going
around about how the sausage is really
made like for example the strike said
nothing to do with this and yes there is
a strike from sag-aftra in the wga right
now and sag has informed us that
entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV shows we just want to appreciate
how hard it is for writers and actors to
work under these conditions and how they
deserve Fair pay there were some great
moments of artistry and secret evasion
let's not Overlook those specifically
the acting of Olivia Coleman Don Cheadle
Samuel L Jackson Charlene Woodard and
everyone else in the cast and ultimately
I do think some amazing bits of dialogue
were written it was just a context
around that dialogue that didn't hit
with us and let's start by saying that
secret Invasion has not disappointed
fans out of a sense of Marvel fatigue in
my opinion I'm not even so that there is
a Marvel fatigue or a superhero fatigue
after two of the big biggest movies this
summer regarding to the Galaxy vol 3 and
Spider-Man across the spider-verse and
Marvel fans from what I can tell still
seem pretty excited about the upcoming
titles I'm also hesitant to blame the
writing now I know a lot of you are like
come on dude and I will admit that yeah
there were some major issues with secret
invasions episode structure it's
internal logic and the character arcs
like it's probably a weird sign how the
episode run times vary so much in length
some people say that they wish that they
had more episodes I honestly think they
could have done with less like in the
six episodes of the series you could
have made one killer two hour film but
talk about some of the specific choices
in the scripts this season yeah it does
not feel great that Maria Hill was
killed off and didn't at all motivate
the final Conflict of the series or that
Soren was killed off off screen or that
the real Nick Fury the hero of the
series had less of a relationship with
the villain than did Gaia who's a
two-tier protagonist who spent the
season waffling with her stances and
suddenly took over in the final battle
and it doesn't feel great that the big
twist of the series that Roadie was a
scroll was learned by Nick Fury at some
point off screen between episodes it
doesn't feel great that the best moments
of die log of the Season occurred
between two known characters we thought
Fury and Rhodey Fury and gravic but then
we learned just really occurred between
Scrolls bullshitting about their
histories but here's the deal I wasn't
in the writer's room of the series I
wouldn't be surprised with a lot of the
people who wrote on the show would feel
the same way I think TV writers often
have to make sacrifices and surrender
battles to a bigger Studio vision and
notes so instead I just want to focus on
some more external evidence-based
reasons that the studio struggled with
secret invasion in particular at the
very least think about it secret
Invasion could have been Marvel's Andor
or Marvel's Peacemaker both of them less
reviewed but well liked and extremely
well executed seasons of Television
Espionage story set in heavily IP driven
worlds Peacemaker was a better secret
Invasion storyline than secret invasion
was so to this end I think Marvel
Studios struggled to overcome three
challenges in particular when it came to
secret Invasion number one we've talked
about before what I call the scale
dilemma in an investigation I did on the
Deep dive Channel I broke down how in
2019 when Marvel only made two to three
movies a year there was only 7 hours and
14 minutes total of MCU content to
account for in 2021 that expanded to 34
hours and 42 minutes across four films
and five Disney plus streaming series
and then in 2022 22 hours and 42 minutes
across three films three Disney plus
series and two special presentations now
to be clear I don't think any of us are
complaining about having too much
content but since Marvel in particular
depends on all of these storylines
interconnecting in the same universe
it's just harder and harder to do that
when you want all these titles to also
have distinct tonal variety and unique
Stakes secret Invasion has to take place
in a world where Tiamat is poking out of
the ozone layer and Captain Marvel's
power set is supposed to be uniquely
tied to an upcoming plot making it
pretty hard for a fourth character to
suddenly get her powers furthermore
Marvel's approach to rely on reshoots
there were apparently extensive reshoots
or secret Invasion and Marvel's tendency
to reconfigure plot lights during
post-production sometimes you can pull
that off like the rooster brothers did
that for Infinity war and end game and
pulled it off but I think it's
especially damaging to the Espionage
genre in which audiences expect
characters to be a up ahead of us and
outsmart each other and keep us guessing
about their plans and to be brilliant
Master tacticians secret Invasion really
just played out as a battle of idiots
who could fumble the least like Fury and
gaia's Avenger DNA plan that was so
dangerously stupid and Nick Fury is
supposed to be one of the cleverest
people in the MCU if you're the kind of
person who likes working on cars but
doesn't have the room in your apartment
for a full garage then the Fast and
Furious miniature collection from van
home might be just what you need van
home is a brand dedicated to developing
unique Collections and build up models
from your favorite fandoms whether
that's Star Wars Marvel or the vast Saga
a phantom subscription gets you
magazines loaded with trivia and stories
about your favorite fandom but also
everything you need to build your very
own family of awesome physics it's
defined Cars the cars at Van home's Fast
and Furious collection are 1 to 43 scale
models made of die-cast metal and
injected ABS plastic they're hand
painted so every detail is film accurate
including the Interiors they've got
rubber tires that you can see or enroll
wherever you want Rio outer space Rome
or just your next family Barbecue with a
fan home subscription you'll get a new
kit every month with easy to follow
instructions on how to put everything
together you'll also get a Dodge Charger
off-road model an exclusive t-shirt a
mug and three posters but just like the
movies it's all about the cars and
family but like a car Centric family and
look at these things they're incredible
to get started with fan home just click
the link Link in the description below
the second issue that I think Marvel
struggled with is sacred Invasion needs
Avengers the reason Brian Michael
bennis's Comet crossover storyline is so
beloved is that it seemed like every
Marvel hero could tie in with it and
indeed everyone pretty much does but in
the MCU in Phase five on Disney plus
it's just really really hard to pull
that off so that it retroactively fits
in perfectly with 15 years of an
interconnected Cinematic Universe and
still stay on budget like at the end of
the day they couldn't afford to bring in
Chris Hemsworth or Robert Downey Jr or
Chris Evans or even Mark Ruffalo to show
up I think I'd pay Julie Louis-Dreyfus
to do this but uh I guess not the series
instead provided two solutions reveal
one long-time Avenger is a scroll in
this case James Rhodes war machine but
gave no answers on when that swap
occurred and even had the gal to ask the
question but not answer it so we're just
kind of left guessing how much of a
beloved character storyline was made up
of Lies there's no catharsis the second
solution they offered was this Final
Super scroll battle between Gaia and
gravic which did feature nods to over 2
20 MCU characters and I'll admit it was
fun to watch but ultimately it was two
characters we cared less about
cosplaying with literal arm sleeves of
more interesting characters it's not the
powers of those characters that we love
it's the faces and the personalities of
Drax and Groot and mantis and Bruce
Banner and Thanos and the rest that
really matter to the fans that plus the
goofy bfx of drax's arm being way too
small for gaia's body it just kind of
left us feeling Hollow but the third
thing that Marvel's really struggling
with is a central vision and really an
identity crisis ultimately what secret
invasion was missing the most and I
think what the MCU desperately needs
right now is a strong central vision for
all of these titles and what identity an
espionage-filled secret Invasion series
would occupy in the overall MCU slate
like when you look at Star Wars Tony
Gilroy was able to outline his vision
for Andor and its Rogue one prequel
timeline with dark grounded spycraft
themes because he was able to pitch that
as a contrast to the Dave filoni side of
Star Wars because filoni has done such
an effective job defining that side of
the brand the fact that Lucas saw that
in Gilroy's pitch document and believed
in him led to Andor being equality if
underwatched title and yes there was
just some amazing goddamn writing on
that show because when characters were
killed off it mattered before Marvel
phase 4 Kevin feige described it as a
response to end game and kind of a reset
okay but for Phase 5 with quantumania
guardians volume 3 and secret evasion
and the Marvel's coming we do not know
what the central vision of Marvel is and
what identity each of these titles is
striving to hit other than I suppose
what She-Hulk made fun of Marvel for CGI
filled unfulfilling final acts but
Marvel has an identity crisis right now
which means some titles are going to be
great if the director has a strong
central vision for it and the studio
didn't interfere with that like as was
the case with guardians volume 3 but
other titles are just gonna feel weird
and confusing as is the case with
quantumania secret Invasion just did not
have its own strong vision for what this
show was going to be about it started as
a show about political conspiracies and
xenophobia really Ended as a show about
American overreactionism and married
life like imagine what secret Invasion
would have looked like if it opened with
President ritzen's address and then a
montage of news anchors and world
leaders getting assassinated some scroll
some human what would happen next that
is what secret Invasion should feel like
that should have been the tone for the
entire series but instead Marvel left us
once again thinking well maybe the next
one will be better I want to know your
thoughts on secret Invasion as a whole
in the comments below if you like what
we're doing at new rockstars please
subscribe to all three of our channels
you can follow me on all social
platforms at eavos thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you